and in Jewish tradition words are very
important and we even Jews the pray
three times a day ask the almighty ask
for his help or her help to keep you
know God please help keep my mouth from
speaking evil because in our tradition
the power of life and death is in the
tongue and the gas chambers and
auschwitz - crematorium Auschwitz didn't
begin with bricks they began with words
ugly words hateful words these words
were met with absence nobody challenged
them nobody questioned them and then
became bricks 9/11 9/11 didn't start
with box cutters or flying planes as
missiles started with ugly words
denigrating Americans the meaning
Americans our values and everything else
the reason slavery can persist it so
long the reason that that there were
lynchings was that words words the mean
african-americans as done you as that
person is not human so if you can use
words in a way to demean and undermine
their humanity that eventually it
doesn't matter what you do because
they're they're not human and it starts
with jokes
it starts with separating as a group the
other you know and we see it we see it
again with bullying and cyber-bullying
it all starts with the joke and and it
builds so yeah look I've had my
differences with Borat with sasha Cohen
I'm old enough to have my differences
with all in a family you're too young to
remember but this was an approach which
says let's make fun of bigotry let's
make let's laugh at bigotry and I argued
with Leonard goldenson and this was the
first show on television which poked fun
at at bigotry and hearsay can you can
you laugh but you make
and and what when the producers claim
was that if you laugh at it you get it
out of your system and the truth is that
Archie Bunker became a hero people were
laughing with him not at him all the
other characters were made simple
and-and-and an idiotic and when when
sasha Cohen did Borat he defended it as
this is the way you know to expose
bigotries to laugh at it but I don't
think that the people when he did a skit
about throwing the Jews down the well
and the people who were applauding I
don't think it was funny I think they
were they were they were reinforcing it
my little test that I sell I still offer
that to the sasha Cohen and he said to
me you gotta learn to take a joke I said
you know what I will why don't you do a
public service announcement for the
anti-defamation league which says a
prejudice is not funny and then you can
make you movies to prejudice